right here with reaction former acting
attorney general Matthew Whitaker along
with the author of the best seller trial
of Century Fox News legal analyst Greg
Jarrett author of another bestseller get
Trump Harvard Law Professor Alan
dershowitz Matt Whittaker let me start
with you you have the the background the
inner workings of the Department of
Justice you explained to me so if
Merrick Garland testified under oath
that Weiss had all this Authority and
didn't need a special counsel status
because he had more Authority and he was
denied on two separate occasions the
ability to go after his investigation
that sounds to me like Merrick Garland
Not only was helping to protect his boss
Joe Biden but also light under oath and
that would be perjury uh based on my
understanding of the law
yeah it would be Sean good to be with
you tonight but I also know how the
Department of Justice works and mayor
Garland is being kept in the dark by a
lot of this he's not communicating with
these U.S attorneys in Los Angeles and
the District Columbia who are doing
doing his dirty work plus the deputy
attorney general who has day-to-day
oversight of those offices certainly is
trying to keep things out of Merrick
Garland's office and I would also you
know Not only would I bring those U.S
attorneys in front of Congress after
they bring the six Witnesses I would
also bring the Assistant Attorney
General in charge of the tax division
who would have had to have approved or
be involved in these cases because all
of those people know a bit and a piece
here but at the end of the day Merrick
Garland was not honest with the American
people and we need to we need the truth
in this case because it just smells
really bad
all right Professor dershowitz let me
get to you in this case now we have six
people uh in real time taking
contemporaneous notes they are
corroborating that Weiss is rightly
complaining that he did not have the
authority to follow through on
prosecutions or charges that he wanted
to bring in in the investigation as it
relates to Hunter and Joe Biden uh that
that Authority that Merrick Garland said
he had did not exist how important how
critical will the testimony of those six
whistleblowers and their notes be in
terms of ascertaining the truth here
well very important and the judge who is
sentencing uh Hunter Biden and who has
to approve of the plea deal must must
call Garland must call Weiss must call
these six Witnesses and must say look
Hunter Biden's lawyers we know you want
the deal to go through justice
department we know you want the deal to
go through but I'm a judge I represent
the people of the United States of
America I want to make sure Professor
who has standing who's going to bring
that before that judge will the judge do
it on their own
an organization like Judicial Watch an
organization that can come in Amicus
cure Ai and say look we can't leave it
to the two parties here they're both
interested in preventing the whole truth
from coming out so judicial Watchers
some other organization comes in and
says we represent the people of this
country you have to call these people as
Witnesses the law provides that a judge
need not accept the plea bargain agree
to by both sides if there is a problem
here and if he concludes for example
that Weiss was denied the ability to
investigate Beyond Delaware then the
deals off because the deal probably ends
any possibility of prosecution in the
District of Columbia or in Los Angeles
and if those were foreclosed in
violation of what Garland said would be
available to Weiss then the deals off
and you have to go back to square one
you have to conclude the investigation
and then you decide whether or not to
make a plea market right now the judge
should not accept this plea bargain
without hearing from Garland Weiss and
the sick Witnesses years I completely
agree well said Greg Jarrett let me take
it at you in a different direction let's
talk about the WhatsApp messages that we
now have from from zero experience
Hunter I'm sitting here with my father
we want to understand why the commitment
made has not been fulfilled blah blah
blah uh by the way just so you know
I will make certain between the man
sitting next to me and every person he
knows and my ability to forever hold the
grudge that you will regret not
following my Direction that's that's
WhatsApp message number one an encrypted
application uh what's that message
number two the bidens are the best I
know at doing exactly what the chairman
wants from the partnership uh can you
explain uh what it is the bidens do so
well and what could they possibly offer
a Chinese Energy company because I'm
having a hard time figuring that one out
I don't know I'm not that smart
well it's the selling out of America for
profit it's the equivalent of a crime
syndicate all the more important that I
agree with the professor that the judge
Mary Ellen uh Noriega
uh put a halt to this put a pause on
this plea deal because the evidence is
compelling that mayor Garland has been
lying when he denied that two U.S
attorneys appointed by Joe Biden halted
felony charges against his son Garland
may have further perjured himself when
he claimed that Weiss had ultimate
authority to charge anywhere and that he
never asked for special counsel status
all of those statements are contradicted
not just by Gary shapley the IRS special
agent but a second IRS whistleblower has
come forward there are other witnesses
as you point out in that pivotal meeting
they were sitting there they heard David
Wise confess he had no power to
prosecute anymore and shapley took
contemporaneous notes they he summarized
it in an email he sent it out to
everybody in an FBI agent Daryl Walden
corroborated it by replying to the email
saying thank you Gary you covered it all
so the question question is are all of
those people lying or is Merrick Garland
and maybe Weiss is lying too because he
told Congress he had Authority but read
the rest of Weiss's statement there's a
critical caveat I have it in front of me
here Authority consistent with the
principles of federal prosecution and
Department regulations well what's that
look it up I did look it up and the doj
regulations State clearly that a guy
like Weiss has no Authority outside his
Delaware District so the federal judge
Noriega should delay approving this
crooked plea deal it wreaks a political
interference corruption lies and a
cover-up Sean you know Matt the The
Whistleblower in an interview tonight uh
said first of all he's talking about 2.2
million dollars in owed taxes and I know
later some some rich benefactor paid it
quote loan I don't know how Hunter is
going to pay it back but they said he
said the president's son he believed
received preferential treatment and
claims he was blocked from pursuing
leads that would have led to Joe Biden
the president of the United States and
that the doj and Biden's attorney deny
special treatment doesn't mean a thing
to me when you have not one but six
whistleblowers they impeached Donald
Trump over a hearsay whistleblower so
I've got to imagine that that if this
judge goes along with that plea deal
that sweetheart slap on the wrist deal
no jail time by Hunter that that too is
corrupted and of itself am I wrong
well it will be because this judge needs
to find out exactly if this is in the
interest of Justice which we've talked
about it's not and you know you talk
about this whistleblower tonight going
on and describing exactly how much in
back taxes Hunter not only avoided but
the responsibility he avoided by not
only paying them by this loan but also
having the statute limitations run on
the two biggest years when he got the
barismo money where he was making eighty
three thousand dollars a month so a
million dollars a year you know all of
that has has passed now and he's facing
very consequential misdemeanor charges
for tax years where he didn't make big
berisma money all right exit uh exit
question yes or no guys I'm just up on
the clock Professor dershowitz if all
this turns out to be true would the
Republicans be right to impeach Merrick
Garland
It's A Hard Sell because impeachment
requires a crime it requires perjury and
perjury requires a specific intent I'd
rather move to trying to find out the
truth first rather than trying to
prosecute people Americans said he had
Authority that he knew he didn't have
and wouldn't give him the authority the
special counsel status he asked for is
that enough to raise that bar for you
I think so because he doesn't he has the
authority Garland has the authority
exactly
and he claimed that he had more power as
a as a you know as an attorney that's
not true but there may have been
underlings that undercut his views I'm
not prepared go to perjury I'm prepared
however to say we must have hearings and
you can't allow this plea bargain to go
fast
if that's all true should he be
impeached last word Greg Jarrett
if he knowingly and intentionally lied
then Garland should be impeached because
perjury would constitute a high crime
and misdemeanor thank you hey Sean
Hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to Fox News YouTube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else